[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm frances
foster i'm constantine kissen and this
is a show for you if you're bored of
people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about
at trigonometry we don't pretend to be
the experts we ask
the experts our fantastic expert guest
this week is a professor of politics at
birkbeck university in london
eric caveman welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much
[Music]
it's great to have you here as always
before we get into the interview itself
tell our viewers and our listeners a
little bit about who you are how are you
where you are what's been your story
well my story i mean i have a very kind
of cosmopolitan background to begin with
so i was kind of born in hong kong grew
up in canada
uh moved to london um you know my i've
got you know jewish chinese latino
in my in my background so i've got that
very kind of international lived in
japan for
eight years um but the study or you know
what i study is nationalism and that's
partly because
if you grow up abroad you're much more
aware of
you know it's problematized the idea of
what is your country what's it
about so i developed this interest in
nations and national identity so that's
something i've
focused on for over 20 years and you've
got a book that
uh what we'll be talking about predom
predominantly in this interview it's
called white shift which is coming out
very soon
yes yeah end of october in the uk uh end
of january in the united states
and you've been kind enough to provide
us an advanced copy which i've read is
absolutely fascinating
it's kind of dynamite i think it's fair
to say
and um you know let's get straight into
that i think the main narrative
uh at the moment when we talk about
populism and nationalism and all these
things is
look it's the rust belt it's poor people
who are freaking out about their job
prospects and
their future economic security and all
of that
and what you do in your book is
essentially debunk all of that
and if it wasn't called white shift i
think it would be called it's
immigration stupid
right exactly so a lot of the uh the
media narrative around populism
immediately after say the trump or
brexit vote
you know turn to you know who voted for
trump or who voted for brexit and where
do they live and you can see that the
cities tended to be
say remain voting and outlying areas
tended to be
for leave and those areas tend to be a
bit more deprived so people kind of jump
to these conclusions well it's the peop
the left behind
they're the ones who voted to leave or
they voted for
trump the problem with that of course is
that you know
just take london as a city it's got a
large number of
people who are not white british it's
got a large number of people with
university degrees
a large number of young people so that
makes it fairly unusual demographically
the only real way to do that study
properly is to take a white working
class
person in london and a white working
class person in the north
in in a mining town for example and
compare them and when you do that you
actually see
if anything that person in london is
slightly more likely to have voted leave
so that's the kind of method where
you're actually looking at individuals
individual level large scale survey data
not looking at these
election maps are talking about opioid
crises or
so on so yeah the first takeaway really
is that
it's almost all about immigration when
we talk about right-wing populism not
left-wing populism podemos and corbin
that is about the economy but
right-wing populism in the west not
again in india or in even in eastern
europe
in the west it's about immigration and
the academic literature is actually
pretty solid on this as well
the academic literature shows this and
wouldn't dispute this now some of course
would dispute it but certainly when it
comes to immigration
a lot of the academic there was a
meta-analysis done which is an
analysis of all the literature and they
they find essentially that
how poor you are whether you're
unemployed or not whether you've lost
your job
those are not things that predict your
immigration attitudes and these are not
things that are driving
right-wing populism so the mainstream
narrative
right now is essentially people have
nothing to
to live on people don't have a job like
you say and they're lashing out
against immigrants because that's where
we normally
channel our anger when we've we've lost
out and whatever
and you say well i say no i say
essentially what this is about
is anxiety over ethnocultural change
threats to identity i mean i'll give you
a kind of question that we might ask
people say in this country we ask
brexiteers
you know white british brexiteers how
concerned are you uh how much of a
problem
is uh pressure on public services zero
to a hundred hundred being
it's a big problem uh and people give it
about a forty you know brexit
leave voters give it about a forty seven
forty eight out of a hundred
and all you have to do is stick the word
immigrants putting pressure on public
services it's the same question
how much of a problem is pressure on
public services but it's
immigrants putting just two words
pressure on public services it goes from
sort of 48 out of 100 to 70 out of 100.
for remainers it's the reverse and
actually it makes sense what the
remainers are doing actually does make
sense because
if the problem is pressure on public
services the part of that problem that
is accounted for by immigrants has to be
smaller
than the problem itself so it makes no
sense to get a number moving from say 48
up to 70
because the problem the immigrant fueled
part of the problem cannot be larger
than the whole problem but that's
just a way of by way of explaining that
this is not driven by
people's worry about pressure on public
service as economic things which is sort
of the narrative of
probably both parties in a way because
that's what they know they've got
economic policy tools
it's also safer because we can talk
about well people are feeling pressure
on
material things schools and hospitals
and that's why they're upset about
immigration
it's not that nasty cultural stuff but
actually it is
that cultural stuff well let's break
that down when you say the nasty
cultural stuff right
what you're not i've read your book very
carefully so you're not saying
that the majority of the people who are
on the populist right
hate immigrants and they're racist right
you're not saying that's i'm not saying
that no
i actually think we need to open up a
conversation about white identity first
of all and secondly something i call the
white tradition of national identity
and to to do so in a fair-minded way so
there is a certain kind of toxicity
around the subject of
white group identity by mitchell
is that right right so
and and you know it never ends well
though it doesn't let me fair when you
get through a group of people together
and go right where why
we identify for being white it tends to
end in
camps and well no i i disagree with you
so for example i don't think
identifying as white or identifying as
black or identifying as hawaiian
you know we have to look at these things
differently i mean all of those
identities
can be abused you can go you can fixate
and be extremist about it but just
if you think about the world you know
eighty percent of the world's countries
have an ethnic majority
you know persians in iran it could be
swanna and botswana
japanese in japan etc those those
you know these people identify with
their group with their culture and
they're not out killing each other now
some will but
but when we think about what are the
predictors of genocide for example
it's it's an it's an ideology that says
this country should only be inhabited
by either a particular group or people
who
adhere to an ideology like socialism or
like islam islamism
and if you don't adhere to that you're
in the way and we're going to
exterminate you
so it doesn't necessarily matter whether
it's a particularist identity like
ethnicity or it's a universalist
identity like islam or socialism there
are extreme versions in moderate
versions and you can have a moderate
version of white identity as you can a
moderate version of
islamic identity and there's nothing
wrong with that and that's sort of the
normal state of affairs
in most countries most of the time so i
think this
focus on white identity is toxic
actually doesn't have
a basis in fact even though we know yes
we're all friends about the nazis you're
wrong
yeah we're all thinking about the nazis
you know i i lost relatives in the
holocaust you know yes
of course um but that's one case and we
actually have to say okay
all of the countries in the world that
have ethnic minorities that
identify with their group and then all
of the places in the world that have a
genocidal
event and we have data sets actually
where we can look at
this question systematically and we find
well actually you have to have a number
of conditions in place
one of which is this exclusivist focus
on identity so it's not just saying
you know we are hindus in india but it's
you know everybody who isn't a hindu is
garbage and must be exterminated that's
that's a very different thing from just
saying we identify as hindu
so you can have moderate versions and
extreme versions of any identity whether
it's
a minority identity or a majority so i i
really
think actually we have to start to think
about
it being you know okay to express a
moderate
white identity or what i mean by that is
ethnic majority identity
because again 80 of the world's
countries have these ethnic majority
identities
if we try and say you can't have that i
actually think
we are making things worse if anything i
think that's the greater risk than if we
say okay
it can be expressed but it's got to be
done in a moderate way
whereas what you would argue we've had
is a blowback against
excessive oppression of people's
attempts to speak their mind about these
issues
which result then in trump and brexit
yeah so
if you look at the trump vote for
example white identity is a major
predictor of the trump vote um the sense
that whites are being discriminated
against
which is largely not true if we think
about economics and politics where
they're
actually doing very well but in terms of
the high culture in terms of the sense
of not being able to express an identity
whereas other groups can on campus which
is something the far right then
uses so it uses something which is
actually true that there is this
double standard in terms of majorities
and minorities being able to express
an identity attachment to heritage and
then it builds
you know the anti-semitism the
anti-islam and all this other stuff
layers that on top uh so i actually
think we're giving
oxygen and ammunition to the far right
by maintaining this double standard
well see if you were like you you
established your oppression credentials
earlier
i have to do that you absolutely i
shouldn't have done it no no no
yeah no just for anyone who doesn't know
us right i'm an immigrant francis
mother's an immigrant
eric you're an immigrant and mixed race
we've got a few other tech guys in the
room
they're all either immigrants or the
descendants of immigrants right so and
the reason we do that is because they're
cheaper
no but so we've established that
right right because if we hadn't that
would be racist right
having this conversation i mean you are
saying essentially why people need to be
able to be proud of being white well to
a to be able to have an eye yeah i mean
to have an identity there's a difference
so there's a social psychology
literature going now 50 60 years and
summarized in a paper by marilyn brewer
actually in 1999 that
there is no correlation between uh
hating an out group and being attached
to your in-group now i actually think
overly fixating on an in-group is
unhealthy as well but what i what i just
want to establish here is that
so in the 2016 american national
election study how warm you feel towards
whites
is not predictive of how cool you feel
towards blacks or muslims actually
there's if anything
a slight positive correlation warmer you
feel towards whites
slightly warmer towards blacks or other
groups um and this is a
finding that's repeated found in many
instances so i think we have to when
we're talking about racism there is real
racism
we have to stick to the definition and
we can't sort of let that definition
creep and expand to encompass anything
that
especially the left doesn't like whether
that's nationalism whether that's
majority group identity
etc that's been part of the problem
because as
that definition has crept out and shut
down debate because when you say
something's racist you're saying it's
disgusting
it's beyond the pale so we can't talk
about it what that does is it then
pushes it off
the agenda of mainstream politics and
that then it's like
saying we can't sell alcohol so who's
going to rush in and fill that gap
uh it's not going to be a mainstream
party it's going to be the sweden
democrats for example in sweden you
couldn't talk about
immigration that was seen as racist boom
incoming sweden democrats
up to you know almost 20 in the last
election right so so that it's
it's it's the issue of a political
entrepreneur
having a market because the mainstream
parties feel this is too hot to handle
and the reason now there are some
instances where the mainstream parties
really should
not touch an issue like segregation you
know
imposing segregation between blacks and
whites you know george wallace
candidate uh in the united states from
the south he said we want segregation
and yes he was able to get a certain
amount of populist support for that
and i think the mainstream parties were
right to say no to that and to push it
off
the agenda but but then if you take that
approach
it's correct for that approach but then
what about talking about levels of
immigration
what about talking about national
identity you see there's a temptation
if you are on the left to want or even
if you are
on the right but you're sort of free
marketeer to want
those taboos to expand and expand so
these
issues are taken off the table
especially if you fear that the
population actually
is disturbed by by these issues and you
don't want to discuss them
democratically well if you can push them
off the table by making them a taboo you
don't actually have to discuss them
and that's actually stored up a lot of
the pressure
that has led to the blowback which i
think we're experiencing or have
experienced since
2012. because it's interesting what you
said there where you said you know
you get these people coming in and
exploiting that which is essentially
what trump did
right how do you and is he talking about
white identity
see i would argue there are racist
undertones to what trump
does for instance you know saying i've
actually had this
conversation with constant i'm half
latin american i think that when he came
out and he said some of these people are
rapists
i think that's a racist comment um what
how how do we i think the question i
really want to ask is
how do we we divorce this idea of having
a white identity
from the sort of the racist
undercurrents
that sometimes can marry itself with
that absolutely so i think you gave a
really good example
when trump said mexicans are he's
generalizing about a group and saying
they're rapists
that is racism or some of them are
rapists i agree with you that's
a racist statement okay um i think we
need to distinguish that from say
saying celebrating the arrival of
christopher columbus for example or
even the wall i mean the wall is
actually not racist
if you think about a wall okay if you've
got an illegal immigration problem
you decide to build a wall you know
there's nothing actually racist about
that
however when you point to a group like
muslims or mexicans and you say
something
nasty or generalizing about them that is
racist because again it's that
distinction that
as i'm using the term it's a distinction
between antipathy to an outgroup
and attachment to an in-group if it's
attachment to ingroup
it isn't it can be racist only if that
attachment leads you to say discriminate
if you're a lawyer and you're hiring
lawyers you discriminate in favor of
whites
clearly people are not receiving equal
treatment under the law
right so sometimes attachment to your
own group can lead to
racist discrimination but generally not
so i i'm certainly allowing that there
are instances where
even if you don't hate another group
even if you just like your own group
you can still be racist by
discriminating against other groups
but in general i think that's not the
case and if we
start to say that that identity
identifying as ethnically english or
white american is is inherently racist i
think you actually piss off a lot of
people and you
if anything you're giving fuel uh to
populism
and in the book one of the things you
talk about is the polarization that's
occurred within society
in terms of attitudes to immigration
between people who might be broad
leasing center or center right
and the the left and the liberals and
you talk about the authoritarians and
the conservatives and their different
interests and priorities on the right
and the liberals on the left so can you
tell our audience a little bit about how
we're differently and how we view
immigration
right so this is one of the keys in my
book is i don't use
say class or age or any of these big
demographics as
as key explanatory factors i tend to
focus on
psychological makeup and there's there's
a number of interesting writers karen
stenner is one
social psychologist uh and there's a
literature on that some people prefer
order and stability and other people
prefer change diversity for example
difference
um and those are preferences it's a bit
like do you prefer to go on holiday
the same place every year or do you
prefer to go to a different place every
year
and these things are to some extent uh
hereditary not
entirely hereditary but between kind of
like a third and a half depending on the
disposition
so you've got people who really do like
their habitual routine they're not
particularly exploratory
and there are a lot of these people and
there's actually nothing wrong with them
they just have a different taste
now so with diversity what i would say
is is
in a liberal society we must tolerate
diversity so that's that to me is
absolutely right
to insist that everybody must tolerate
tolerate difference
uh but the second question becomes what
do you prefer difference over
more difference over less difference or
or differ greater difference over
homogeneity and actually
that is a taste it's different from
tolerance
or toleration it's preference
right and if we actually look at where
people move to residentially
there's very very little difference
between white liberals and white
conservatives they tend to gravitate to
very white areas
right so i mean i'm not i'm not accusing
liberals of anything i'm just saying
yeah
and then okay but
people's actions and also in terms of
friendship networks
and who people marry a lot of the
behaviors
actually belie the fact that actually
people are preferring
their own not entirely not exclusively
um
but it's just to say that you know it's
a you know some people have a preference
for more change and diversity so what
that then means is
when you when it comes to something like
immigration policy
you can't go out there and just say we
must celebrate diversity and if you
don't
you're a bad person because actually
people are wired differently now we
don't want to necessarily go the other
extreme and say
diversity is bad we don't actually but
what we want to do is say there's
differences in the population
we have to respect those differences to
some extent if you try and kind of
push this idea that everyone must prefer
diversity
it's a bit like saying everyone must
prefer to go on holiday somewhere new
each year
actually you're going to run up against
a problem which is you're actually going
to wrangle people and stenner's work
shows that
in fact by pushing a diversity narrative
you're actually triggering a lot of the
these were called authoritarian
authoritarians in the literature who
prefer that order
and stability they react negatively to
that message so if you're actually going
to diffuse
if you're going to actually diffuse that
threat or diffuse the popular what's
driving populism you need a different
message which might be
it might be one of saying well
immigrants are coming but they're
assimilating
and things aren't changing that much
that would be more the kind of message
that would work
for people who like stability but again
you don't want to say that to
people who like change and diversity so
you've got to have different messages
it's just to say that there is nothing
innately better about preferring
difference and change
to preferring stability and this is one
of the things again one of these
fuzzy lines that people get wrong is
they collapse
the difference between tolerating
difference which we we must
in a liberal society and preferring
difference which is
what what i would call isaiah berlin the
liberal theorist would call positive
liberalism where you're actually saying
this is the idea we want everybody to
push towards and that's when i think
things get polarized because if you're
starting to push people
towards something that they don't
believe in then you are actually going
to polarize society and i think that's
one of the mistakes
actually that progressives have made is
there is this assumption that if you
don't love
diversity change openness that you must
be a terrible person
i mean you raised that point and we were
talking about white indigenous cultures
i used to
work a lot in the east end of london
and one thing that i noticed like you
said a lot of them would be pro brexit
or lee voters white working class
but what i also noticed as well is that
there tended to be
a sort of resentment because they would
notice that people
so immigrants would be coming in they'd
be they'd be
in an area for a period of time and then
they would move on
whereas the white essentially the white
population would remain
in that area do not think a lot of that
is as well is that resentment that they
feel that they're not getting
a good end of the deal as it were
and what they want is a politician to
come and come in
like trump and redress the balance
well it depends what you mean by a deal
i mean
in the brexit vote it is true that
people who were poorer were somewhat
more likely to vote leave
so there is there's some truth to it in
the brexit vote whereas in the trump
vote there's this
almost zero evidence for that what i
would say is that it's true that there
is some of that but
by far you know a much more important
question than whether people are
deprived or
or are not being able to move would be
something like do you support the death
penalty or what's your views on
immigration you know these are
these are much deeper questions in terms
of getting at that cultural attitude i
mean this is one of the reasons why
education
having a degree or not is so much more
important for predicting
the populist right voting than income so
you can be a wealthy
plumber for example and you're very
wealthy you're very safe and secure
but because i mean because that
educational qualification getting a
degree is linked to
certain kinds of world views and
cultural attitudes it's a much more
powerful predictor of
support for the populist right so again
it's tapping a more cultural orientation
rather than
material orientations um and and even
when it comes to for example
resenting politicians or the system
that too is not a predictor of populist
right voting so you'll
you know brexiteers um voters for the
green party versus for the labor party
or
especially for corbin but there isn't
really a difference when you ask
questions like
you know decisions should be made by the
people and not politicians or
westminster politicians or remo there
are a number of these questions in the
british election study which
uh which all show that this is not
something that predicts uh support for
brexit and i think we have to go by the
way this is the other thing
i talk about a lot in the book is we
really have to go to these large scale
individual level data sets to be able to
control for these
you know you put income in there you
stratify by age so you can control for
all these different effects
and once you do that you actually see
how unimportant something like
income is compared to these attitudes
uh death penalty is the clearest one
because that gives you a much stronger
take on
whether someone voted for brexit or
voted for leave than than something like
class
oh really so if you if you agree with
the death penalty you're far more likely
to be a lead voter
absolutely yeah wow
and it's it's is it mark of like
conservatism or authoritarianism is that
yeah so it's a mark of what they call
authoritarianism which which i think is
you know somewhat unfortunate term
you know reflects the the orientation of
academia which is fine i mean of course
we can think what we want about the
death penalty but it's it's also linked
to views on child rearing strict versus
permissive so strict child rearing views
on death penalty
would be another one so these kinds of
um
predictors which all fall under the
rubric of authoritarianism that's a much
more powerful
uh predictor of say populist right
voting
than anything related to class or income
all right well we are where we are
with with this right with immigration so
and and with the whole conversation
uh if we accept everything that you say
in the book which is
right that's what's driving it what
what do you project going forward if if
we keep doing what we've been doing
right well here's the thing right so in
the book the other part and i mean the
book's entitled white shift and the
first part of white shift is really
about whites declining
as a share of the population across the
west so and
in the extreme case might be canada
where it's sort of
in 2006 it might have been about 80
white 20
minorities 2106 it's going to be 80
roughly non-white 20 so that's kind of
that's the most rapid change
uh you know it won't be that quick in
britain in britain it'll still be about
50
white by the end of the century and in
the u.s it'll be somewhere in between
um that's kind of white shift one which
is leading to this
you know these these decline in security
in the white population which is fueling
populism
making immigration such a key issue uh
and
polarization but if you actually go sort
of 50 years beyond
so trailing that initial white decline
is the second meaning of white shift
which is
what i'm arguing is going to happen is
that the white
majorities are actually going to absorb
large numbers of
non-white groups essentially through
intermarriage voluntary intermarriage
already happening the fastest growing
group is the mixed race group
um and so if you just look at
projections of the mixed race group in
britain
going way out and you know of course
with all the caveats about these
long-term projections
assuming that the rate of intermarriage
remains the same regardless of what
happens to inter
to immigration levels you know by the
end of this
you know by the mid-century it's only
about seven percent or so mixed race
by the end of the century it's like
almost 30 percent
and then 50 years later it's like 75 so
you get this kind of
exponential curve simply because anyone
who's mixed
a mixed race background you know myself
might be
an incl an example of that a quarter
chinese so i anyone i marry then
you know my kids will be counted as
mixed right
the secondary question of how they're
treated whether they're treated as white
or not is a secondary question but still
the proportion of the population that
has some uh non-white background in
britain will will
begin to increase exponentially the
question then will be
well how does that mixed race majority
which i'm arguing will kind of take over
as the majority how do they identify and
i'm kind of arguing that they
will mainly or they will selectively
tend to emphasize their european
ancestry
simply because at the global level
that's what's going to be distinctive
about them
whereas the non-european parts of the
world which will be economically much
more
powerful and also demographically much
more powerful i mean
there will be more of a sense of that is
going to be the distinctiveness but
what it does of course mean is that yes
the typical
quote-unquote white person will be you
know will have darker features will be
more
you know look more like what we would
call mixed race today
so that that's kind of the very
futuristic take on this
so the three of us are a good example of
the future that's what yeah basically
yeah because i i i find it very
interesting you're talking about
people's fear and
that's never been a fear of my number
one because my mother is latin american
number two
i spent a lot of time in latin america
and that's essentially what the
population is like
do you think that it's right is probably
the wrong word to use for it but do you
do you understand why people have this
fear
that you know that you know that we are
going to become an inverted commas less
white
because to me it's well that's just my
family that's how i've grown up so it's
for me it's nothing to fear
at all right so so two things on that
one is that
latin america you're right that that's
what's happened there but there are
it's not necessarily the direction that
we would want to go even though we
probably or we may be
moving in that direction because latin
america has a racially stratified system
where
lighter skin people tend to be
over-represented in politics top jobs et
cetera
more of a model i think are what you
know what you see with the maori and the
hawaiians and
native indians where you know whether
you are more or less purely native
indian doesn't mean you're more or less
you know your class your income your
opportunities aren't affected so much
um i think you can have that kind of a
society so there are groups like
in central asia like the turkmen or or
the pashtun and these other groups where
you know you have people who look very
white and you have people who look very
south asian and
that doesn't seem to be the basis for
social stratification so
yeah i would hope we could avoid the
latin american
model if possible um but the other thing
is we don't want to be like
the question about fear no i think yeah
i think we have to address that fear
because no
everybody this is the point about white
identity and
and also what i call the white tradition
of national identity which is this idea
that
i'm attached to being american let's say
um
america has a traditional ethnic
composition which is a white majority a
black minority etc or
britain has a traditional ethnic
composition which is a white british
majority and minorities
and conservatism a lot of these things
are conservatism rather than racism
being attached to
ethno-traditions that tend to give a
country part of its
uniqueness and so that people are don't
want to see those
those particularities erode or they want
to see them erode more slowly
right so there's there are many shades
of gray it's like okay i'm okay with
a certain amount of change but not rapid
change and all that nuance tends to be
crushed out in an
argument where it's either you're for
openness or you're closed you know
actually a lot of people are in between
they're okay maybe with some change but
they want to slow it down i mean that's
sort of
where a lot of people are on the
immigration question
um so yeah i think that's understandable
i don't think the fears i'm not actually
sure how much of this is
fear as much as a sense of loss
you know one of the best questions for
predicting immigration attitudes is
things in america were better in the
past um you know that kind of thing so
but people are attached to the way
things were when they were 20 years old
growing up they see you know another
question would be i don't recognize my
country anymore you know these sorts of
things and that's just
tapping into that cultural conservatism
which i do think has to be distinguished
from
you know i hate latinos or i hate
muslims which is a
clearly very racist thing so i think a
lot of this is actually people's
expression of
a kind of conservatism now the question
is what do you do with that
and part of my what i'm saying is part
of it is you have to
um you have to listen to that you have
to say okay that's a valid because some
people are driven by culture some are
driven by economics i mean it's a valid
concern
you're not going to get everything you
want because we're a democracy and some
people want more immigration and there's
the economy and
which needs immigrants and so on so
we're going to come to an accommodation
and i actually think that would be
better because people would feel okay
i've been heard
i haven't been shouted down as a racist
but i can't have everything i want
because there are we have to pay the
pensions and so on
or or some other reason um so i think
you can
actually get at those fears and also the
other thing is i think you need to have
a vision
uh for what's going to happen to the
white majority if you just say
you guys are going to shrink um we're
going to get more diverse celebrate that
it's just that's actually it'll work for
the more cosmopolitan-minded members of
and this is again down to psychology
some people like that change and they're
going to embrace that but
for a significant chunk of the
population that's not going to wash
they're going to want
some vision of where they're going and
partly that's why this
idea of white shift is okay you know it
is true that
what i'm arguing here is that this mixed
race group is essentially going to carry
forth
the memories the myths the history of
this what is currently the white group
if people can if if the white majorities
can see something positive in that
then maybe they can say okay we've got a
positive future too
no we're not just yesterday's news you
know i think some way of
giving them a future whereas if you just
say
we're getting more diverse and that's
great i think that's that's going to
further the kind of polarization that
we're seeing
so islam sounds like the prescription
that you have is
it would be reducing the levels of
immigration while reassuring
the white majority that immigrants who
come here are going to integrate they're
going to become part of society they
will
intermarry and we all live happily ever
after together
yeah yeah so so part of this is is to
say that you know for
the average person thinks the number of
immigrants or the number of muslims is
two or three times higher than it
actually is
so we've if we've got a problem of the
problem is that
the narrative of change and diversity is
dominant and what we
what we need more of is the narrative of
actually there's a lot of people
intermarrying and actually you know all
those european immigrants their kids are
identifying as white british and they're
being you know essentially they're part
of
you and the afro-caribbeans half of the
marry out and
and the mixed race offspring marry
mostly whites
and this so there's a narrative of kind
of melting uh
and reducing the threat that actually
they're joining you
you know and that that in fact they're
not so different i mean that's the kind
of thing
that you wanted to emphasize and it's
completely under the radar
all of that knowledge about how much
voluntary assimilation is going
even muslims not so much in this country
but like in france
you know over half i think it's about
half of algerians
french algerians marry outside the group
um so a lot of french muslims are
actually secular and they're marrying
out and nobody knows that you know these
are the kinds of things
that need to be more widely known so
that people are actually can think okay
you know it's not a case of we're just
going to be outnumbered
and threatened so part of what i
advocate is
moving to a different style of political
communication especially for
conservative whites
you have to have different messages you
can't go to minority groups and say hey
you guys you're being assimilated isn't
that great
so but that's okay i mean i think you
politicians do this all the time i mean
you know they have
slightly different messages and yeah but
sorry
yeah i just want to finish on that but
you would also if i
please correct me if i'm wrong you also
do say in the book the immigration
levels need to come down
well yes well i don't i'm not making a
prescription what i'm saying is that
if the if the public is not comfortable
with the rate of ethnic change and
they're willing to pay the economic
price
well then the immigration numbers should
come down um
i'm saying that maybe when the majority
gets comfortable with this idea that
of a similar that they're growing
through assimilation then maybe they'll
relax a bit and then maybe
that those numbers will come back up
again but one of the problems that i
see particularly with that left
narrative that says
this is you know it's racist to be in
favor of reducing immigration especially
reducing immigration because you're
uncomfortable with the ethnocultural
consequences i mean that is still
essentially a taboo i mean even steve
bannon you know
uh was interviewed when he had that uh
interview with the economist
and he was saying i'm an economic
nationalist which is nonsense actually
if you look at the support base
and what drives the trump vote it is not
economic nationalism it is essentially a
cultural
sense of cultural laws um so because of
that
taboo over uh what i would call sort of
this idea of casting ethno-traditional
conservatism as racism
attachment to your own group if you're
white as racism because of that
narrative it prevents open discussion of
this
and actually i think it makes things
worse in many ways i mean i think the
brexit vote for example
to some extent the brexit vote was an
outcome of people who are upset at
immigration
more upset at non-european than european
immigration by the way and if you
actually
look at the polling the survey data on
this
they couldn't actually express
themselves
no politician could articulate that fear
directly so
this kind of got diverted into punching
the eu now i'm not saying that there
weren't
grievances around the eu and brussels
being bureaucratic and remote
and free movement and everything but
still that was an acceptable narrative
is to to hit the eu and so it all you
know because their
immigrants are white we can go after
that we can claim they're
putting pressure on services or they're
competing for jobs and whatever and
actually the outcome of that
might be quite negative for the british
economy that's one example another
example is to say okay
people are upset about immigration it's
because of pressure on public services
so if you are an immigrant you have no
access to public services
you know for five years or whatever it
is so so any attempt to tighten up
and all that just does is is injure
you know an immigrant who wants to go to
the hospital or wants to get
who needs maybe income support so
basically what you're saying is we're
having a fake conversation
we're talking about the economy we're
talking about immigrants taking jobs or
taking hospital beds where really that
isn't the core concern that's driving
the populace right
exactly exactly and and it's somebody
who you know
typically someone will be against
immigration first and then they'll look
for
the reasons that are acceptable it might
be
pressure on services so jonathan height
has this idea of the elephant and the
rider
the elephant is the driver and then we
tell ourselves the story that's the
rider
so i think this this stuff about
services and jobs is a bit of a rider
story
not to say that it has no impact but if
you look for example
you ask people is immigration a problem
in your local area
20 say it's a problem is it a problem
nationally 70
now that kind of tells you that this is
much more of a national level issue then
it's not about local
cons local concerns do matter in some
cases boston
in lincolnshire or some of the midwest
united states towns that have had rapid
increases
in in hispanic population then yes you
will you will always see this
jump in support for populist right but
for most people
it's what's going on nationally that
counts
yeah yeah because you you were talking
about
so you know the worries about us for
instance muslim immigration or the rest
of it
isn't a lot of this based in aesthetics
um i'll give you an example
i was going to uh my dad is from wigan
which is a very poor part of
obviously for those of you who are
watching overseas a very poor part of
north of england
and i was going to watch a rugby league
match which was
everybody from up north came to wembley
to watch a rugby match and
the supporters were talking to me and
they were going oh i can't recognise
london anymore
before it used to be filled with
cockneys like you and
right and on one hand right i'm you know
i'm born in london but if i'd taken more
from my mother's side of the family
i doubt we'd be having that conversation
right so do you see i just
okay what i would say though is so so
what what what's yeah but
i'm saying that a lot of it is just
isn't it a lot of it that just people
see something completely different to
them and recall in fear
and it's almost an emotional response
okay
so it depends if they see people who are
different
and fear them or hate them yeah then
that's racism and i think that's
deplorable yeah
if what they're saying is i was attached
to london that had a certain character
and i feel a sense of loss yeah i think
that's very different i don't think that
is i think that's just
a conservatism yeah and and people
should be able to express that sense of
loss
and they should actually even be able to
say i don't want that to change as fast
you can imagine you can see it so we can
look at say african americans in harlem
or
black britain's in brixton here in
london you know let's say brixton and
of course we know it's become a lot less
black be become more
white as as hipsters and others are
moving in so
you might you might be an afro caribbean
in brixton saying i miss the way brixton
used to be
and my view is actually that's just
conservatism that's not
that you hate white people right so
that's the kind of subtle differences
that i think we need to talk about but
if you're saying i hate those
you know white people and that's
different that that then is so that's
why i think we need to make these
distinctions
and actually if you do surveys and you
ask liberals and conservatives their
views of
why you know people don't like
immigration you will tend to get
liberals thinking that it's the the
conservatives hate
minorities and the conservatives will
say no they just are attached to their
own group
so we're getting people kind of talking
past each other
and kind of seeing the other in a
negative light
and i actually don't think that's
necessarily the case
[Music]
how do you think we got here eric how do
we get to this point
where expressing those concerns that
might be conservative about the way
things used to be
or things are changing too fast when did
that become racist
and how did that become racist right
well that's a very interesting story
which i kind of go to in the book i'm
not
so much of a fan of these theories which
say that this
social justice warrior stuff is a new
thing and it's related to social media i
mean of course those things
have an impact but i actually think you
have to put this in the context of a
much longer
ideal law intellectual history and
ideological development of the left that
goes back even 200 years
to utopian socialism and anarchism we
only have five minutes okay five minutes
okay so so what i mean is
all right i'll try i'll try and make it
short so basically
there's a fusion of of of two ideas one
is what i call well not me but other
sociologists have called modernism which
is this idea of
anti-tradition new and different is is
better essentially that's what we're
about new and different
um and that if you look at modernist
intellectuals in the united states for
example
uh their view was that the wasp white
anglo-saxon protestant culture
was stifling boring and you know that
you had the prohibition of alcohol in
1920. so they reacted against that and
and they said well look at these
expressive groups like african-americans
with their jazz
and greeks and how wonderful are these
exotic people and
and how how boring and awful are our our
group and that's kind of like the
beginnings
then of this kind of trope which is sort
of a bit of an academic word but this
narrative of
uh of kind of being against your own
group the adversary culture now it's not
a bad thing to be
critical of your own group you don't
want to be just completely saying my
group's the best and that's it
so so you have to have that and you need
cosmopolitans i mean i actually think
that you have to have space for people
to be
citizens of nowhere or whatever but um
essentially that criticism that critique
of the majority culture
actually then becomes the dominant
culture in the high culture
um so this starts to happen you know
even in the 50s you know you had the
beatniks and you had a number of
intellectuals who were again talking
about square
white culture and and all of this but it
didn't quite have the same edge of you
know white privilege you're awful
uh but it was but it was a similar sort
of sentiment and then we get into
the 60s and 70s with the expansion of
television in the university sector and
this becomes
the dominant motif in the high culture
and once that happens and then it
becomes something that you have to buy
into
because academia then changes and and we
talked about this
earlier where um the left-right ratio
amongst the professoriate goes for some
something like it goes from something
like two to one in 1962
particularly in the social sciences and
humanities it's it's kind of you know
ten to one or something like that so you
get a
complete uh domination over time
because of the baby boomers moving into
academic positions and something similar
happens in parts of the media but it's
never quite the same in the media it's
really academia where you get this
complete uh change over and that and
then they bring their mores with them
and one of them
is this idea that you know white
identity is racist
worry about ethnic change is racist it's
never actually you will never find
a clear statement or a political theory
defense of this in philosophical terms
in any of the literature
you will find it in the critical race
the radical stuff which is basically
ideology dressed up as academic research
but
in terms of the respect to top journal
political theory you won't find a
statement of this but that all of a
sudden it becomes the case that
talking about immigration is a racist
thing it was less the case
you know in britain britain actually had
a more open conversation but
u.s sweden germany many countries you
really didn't have
it was seen as very taboo and this is
part of the reason why we see these sort
of sudden
the sudden emergence of the afd in
germany or the sudden emergence of the
sweden democrats
because there simply was nobody willing
to touch those issues politically
now we've said that sort of harking back
in this nostalgia
and wanting the country as it used to be
isn't racist
do you think trump and this right-wing
populism is here to stay
and do you think it's going to be a
factor or do you just think it's
a political blip as it were yeah i mean
i i should say by
you know that conservatism isn't racist
but it doesn't necessarily mean it's the
right thing to do so but
i just think it's a perspective we
should be debating yeah um
the populism is it here to stay i think
right now it is because
the the ethnic shifting is making the
majority
insecure it's bringing cultural issues
more to the surface
and this is actually by you know cutting
across the old left right
political divide which used to be about
redistribution versus
versus free market that's becoming less
important whereas the cultural
the culture wars if you like around more
or less
diversity and change versus you know
tradition and continuity that's becoming
a bigger issue
um yeah if you look at the european case
in nine out of ten european countries
after 1996
you look at the migration numbers you
can look at the rise in media stories
about immigration tracking that and
tracking that
is support for the populist right and
concern about
immigration so and when and so actually
the the numbers are very solid in
showing how
immigration is very much the driver um
now if immigration falls as it has that
will take some of the steam out of the
populist right
and it has actually if you really look
at the numbers that these numbers peaked
at the peak of the migrant crisis have
fallen back a little bit
um but i think underlying this are all
these unanswered questions about
who are we what's the future of of the
country in terms of its traditional
ethnic composition
and and that's why i think actually if
politicians were honest and addressed
that and said
that's a valid concern there is going to
be change
we've heard you we've taken your
concerns on board immigration is
actually going to be
lower than it other than might be
optimal for the economy
because we're listening to your cultural
concerns i actually think that would be
the way forward
um but that isn't happening eric it's
not happening at all right
are you concerned by the direction that
we're going in
well what's happening is that these
populist right parties have emerged
and started posting these very high
numbers and you've had brexit and trump
that's actually broken the taboos around
some of these subjects so in sweden now
all the parties are talking about
reducing immigration
which they have to in order not to lose
those voters to the
sweden democrats i think actually the
breaking of some of those taboos
is a good thing but some of the taboos
actually needed to be in place so i
think now you're seeing these burqa bans
you know i don't agree with some of the
anti-muslim stuff so
particularly bans on freedom of
religious expression
so i think that's where this you've
started this process of rolling back the
taboos but then it can overshoot and go
too far
right that's the risk um and maybe
poland and hungary we even see
some of the results of that so you know
but i think this is the risk when you
when you don't address these problems uh
let them get out of control then they
take on a dynamic of their own
um so you know the politicians aren't
well they're beginning to address it i
think
i would say there's been an improvement
in the sense that more countries are now
willing to
discuss levels of immigration you know
and that wasn't the case before so maybe
we'll get to a stage where the center
parties will take over this issue and
say okay
we will keep the numbers you know modest
to what the population is comfortable
with hasn't happened in britain though
so far has it well
there's been a discussion about
immigration in britain um
and of course if you're part of the eu
obviously you can't control the numbers
but even the non-european numbers were
quite high in britain so
i do think it's partly happened in
britain it's happened in britain a lot
more than in
in some other countries so britain was
certainly having
a more open conversation than sweden or
germany and i do think that
you know if the numbers continue to be
higher than what people want there will
be pressure on the
mainstream parties the mainstream
parties i think are somewhat responsive
i think they will
pay attention to that issue so it's not
the case it's not the same situation as
sweden prior to 2014 where they said
we won't even we're going to close our
ears and that's something we don't talk
about and
you know that is a particularly bad
situation
so i actually think the mainstream
parties are learning and
are kind and that's also on the left the
center left in in a number of countries
denmark would be one of them
are moving in that direction as well um
but again i
if there is a worry i think it might be
that you know the stigmatization of
muslims which is something that
is i think a toxic bad thing you know
it's one thing to be against
um to say that that the burqa is is
you know doesn't allow a woman the right
to express it so i think that's fine to
to sort of make a cultural case for it
but to ban it legally uh i think's
problematic well you're you're a real
liberal
traditional sense of the word you
believe in freedom um
well it's it's absolutely fascinating um
we're almost out of time
um tell me i always like to ask this
question of people who work in a field
in which they are not necessarily
representative of the mainstream opinion
what's it like being you in academia
right well um come back to me after the
book's published
i know i'd say already there is a sense
in which you know
uh quite a few people are are are not
pleased with
with some of the things that that i say
but i think that in the field i'm in
which is
quantitative political science you know
if you've got your numbers behind you i
think
most of those people are actually pretty
fair-minded and most
most academics i think are center-left
you know there is a significant far-left
group i mean i'm not going to gloss that
but
you just have to say well i'm going to
deal with the people who are civil i can
have
massive disagreements with people
politically
but we can still be civil you know and
so i think that's
the academia you still can at least i
think uk academia is poss
it depends it's department to department
i would say in my department yes um
slight west side story yeah yeah exactly
but i know that in some others there's a
lot of conformity
um and so it's probably harder if you
have all it takes is a few very
outspoken individuals
to sort of chill and make it a much more
polarized and
well or a more difficult environment i'd
say but i don't think the uk is yet in
the same boat as the united states where
you have these
completely rabid departments and and and
you know there are the climate that kind
of climate like evergreen state and
middlebury and you know there hasn't as
far as i'm aware there hasn't been
anything quite that extreme in britain
uh let's hope it doesn't get there yeah
let's hope
let's hope because that is a big like in
terms of what's happening outside of
academia
that's such a huge problem is the
inability to have honest genuine
conversations
it's like when i talk to somebody that i
disagree with
face to face and we actually have a
genuine conversation and we both come
away from
having learned something i'm almost
surprised every time because that's so
counter to the kind of conversations
that we're now used to having on twitter
on facebook or whatever
right you know what i mean oh no i i
think you're absolutely right and this
gets to the heart of this problem with
these
taboos because you get people who are so
committed to this
what i call left modernism and this
vision of you know equality and
diversity this kind of utopia and if
you're in the way of that you're not an
ally
and somehow we got to get you out of the
way and so i can't tolerate you i got to
suppress you or
and part of it also gets to a belief
that human beings are blank slates and
that if we can just choke off the supply
of
messages that are countering our utopia
you know if we can just silence
them those people then we won't have a
problem because we know people are
essentially
clay to be molded um and so if we can
control the information supply
then we can get what we want and so the
focus is always on shutting down and
controlling
um and actually i just think that's
that's just not
human nature i mean you've got
differences in some people people aren't
just
blank slates uh you know and they're not
going to be fooled so i think
you know i i think it's a self-defeating
strategy some people are blank slates
i've met a few in my time maybe i've
taught a few as well
well listen eric it's been a fantastic
interview uh thank you very much for
coming to speak to us
the question we always like to ask at
the end is what is the one issue that
no one's talking about that we ought to
be talking about um
minority supporters of populist right
parties so minority trump voters would
be one
my mother being one oh really my
mother's a latino trump voter oh really
she loves him well almost 30 percent of
latinos voted for trump
um here's a here's an interesting one a
question was asked after the
charlottesville riots
uh yeah which which hopefully our your
viewers will be
familiar with which was around this um
confederates a couple of them were there
all right okay okay so so the
charlottesville right
um they asked a number of questions like
uh
why you know white americans are under
threat in in america today something
like that
um whites are under threat in the
country today
70 of latino and asian trump voters
replied yes to that question
uh which is not that different from
white trump voters answer to that
question or
it's very important to protect and
preserve the european christian heritage
of the united states you know asian and
latino trump voters
something like 55 percent you know said
yes so there's actually
quite an interesting phenomenon of
ethnic minorities who are patriotic
and part of their patriotism is an
attachment to the way the nation is
culturally
so it's it's really a mistake to think
that minorities are automatically going
to go
in favor of multiculturalism they're
going to split most of them actually
will support
the multicultural vision but actually
there's a polarization there
as well very interesting all right
eric thank you very much for coming on
your book is called white shift it's
released on
october 25th in the uk uh not till the
end of january
in the united states all right well as
francis takes a massive sneezing
perfect time as we're about to end the
episode um
get the book when it comes out it's i've
read it it's absolutely fascinating
it's a great great book uh i think you
as i said to you before we started the
interview you're probably gonna get
slammed from the left
and from the right which is exactly
where we are
uh and i think that probably means
you're doing something correct
i was going to say doing something right
but you're doing something correctly
which is trying to to be in the middle
it's what we try and do in the show it's
like
you know the the right is going right
and the left has gone
wherever it's gone it's going crazy as
well and i think moderate people in the
middle who are interested in truth and
facts and evidence
need to come together and have these
conversations and try and you know make
society
uh more harmonious as we move forward
and i think that's if people were to
actually read your book instead of
reading three sentences and getting
annoyed about it i think that's where
it's headed so thank you very much for
coming to speak to us
uh get the book if you enjoyed it
obviously as always subscribe to the
youtube channel
click that bell button uh do you want to
do the social media stuff yes
um yep if so if you're enjoying it
please follow us
on trigger pod at uh instagram on
twitter
uh trigonometry on facebook and uh
i think that's yeah that's about it
that's it and eric before we let you go
your twitter handle is uh at epka
e-p-k-a-u-f-m e-p
kaufman well we'll get that we'll get
that in the video so
make sure you follow eric you're always
tweeting and retweeting interesting
articles so that's right
plenty of stuff for you to get into
thank you very much and enjoy your week
we'll see you in a week's time for
another fantastic episode
see you later
[Music]